o campeão solar e de tentar apresentar
aqui nesta plataforma de acessibilidade
eu fui vítima um senhor está fazendo a
contagem de áudio desta idéia foi
construída é fato de conhecimento humano
ligado à sua partilha do filme atleta é
a grande importância que esta condição
de definir onde hoje está o seguinte ó o
player do asa vai aproveitando esse
perfil que nós desenvolvemos para
construir a partir daí permitindo assim
muitos anos e conseguimos que buscar o
chanthu mais gostoso estar juntos com as
religiosas aspirações por semana após a
quinta vez que são de mais importante é
uma miséria em computação
esse é o focinho em cimento distância de
brasília tinha esquecido
no entanto talvez mais forte ainda
por outro lado acho que a gente também o
melhor pagador que a vítima chegou a
conhecimento eo eterno continua positiva
caiu 15 pessoas também vai ser muito
melhor
de fato o um número diferente tanto
gostam diferente mais cruel é fato é
nosso amigo final
a forma como olhamos para as coisas como
- a escolha dos convênios das turmas
convênios mundo como sachs tecnologia é
essa é nossa 20 lá mas em frente corpos
de via twitter
é mais uma vez é grande o grande
paradoxo da entrega em vários estados
a informação chega a qualquer momento
no entanto vocês mas a minha filha de
qualquer gestão
enquanto isso o que ele irá receber
assegurado como a capacidade de ser um
outro lado conteúdo bem estruturada e
capacidade que tenho de acertar nenhuma
uma eficiência permanente temporária ou
não tenho preferência nenhuma é
a cdu é nosso sustento diferentes formas
em diferentes contextos de uso
diria que é melhor definição da cidade
os principais tudo nos sentidos juros ea
guia os meus problemas planos do meu pai
pessoas que vão ver é tem a ver com a
seguir haverá a informação quando nos
deparamos com o documento oferece
digitalizados em imagens que também
estão o silas porque não foi possível
acessar o conteúdo da imagem
quando temos documentos por point
minutos continuou mal estruturados e que
tornam difícil a sua leitura
quando não temos consultar sites web que
estou mal estruturados e onde se torna
complicado aceder à informação
uma das coisas que enfim que está muito
muito presente condição é segurada nível
do conceito é que eu gosto de construir
é é precisamente a relação que a empresa
conceituada cidade com deficiência que
não agrada nada isto é assegurada é
muito mais que isso e na sociedade atual
é cada vez mais último da unidade quando
estamos a produzir alguma coisa cível de
andar de que vai beneficiar não só os
destinatários das atividades precisar
dessa semifinal mas muitas outras
pessoas quando nós pensarmos em termos
de sociedade física em criar é fazer um
carro porque é anunciada acesso souza em
cadeira de rodas
esqueçamos que esta rampa mas também ser
utilizada por exemplo pessoas como
branca de neve o que é bom ou mau
voltas é um pouco como por exemplo a
chegar ao ego quando falamos da sigla
idaho é que estamos a falar de um site
depois vai ser nosso é mais fácil ser
educado pessoas com limitações mas com o
site a síria já matou site mais leve mas
fluindo mais rápido é mais compatível
com outros dispositivos 29 quase todos
nós vamos abrir o olho e diz que vai
falar algumas coisas
agora a questão é de forma que consigo
estruturar esse documento não era que os
torna visível para todos e acessível de
diferentes formas é assim tão complicado
não não é é um pouco isso que este
projecto o tempo de mistificar um pouco
todas estas toda a inscrição
é o lado do nível está blindado
construir a frente pensando em todos os
potenciais virtuais é uma pena menor
a high school então aí velhos a fio era
construir a se cuidar porque a partir da
base do início da marcha ea gente foi o
uso assim existem é sempre passar é o
teclado não só porque como usar tudo
obrigado caminhos que nós vemos todos os
dias quantas podem ver tudo o que foi
passado simplificar com mais filha e
funk evento voltado não só entende como
também é e outros flagrantes no chez
pensamos também dependendo de diversos
jogadores com a tragédia
a idéia era não só simplificar das
pessoas para criar essa facilidade 200
nas ferramentas que não é coerente com a
esposa mas era trabalho que estas
instruções fossem efetivamente da silva
está todos nós temos o formato vídeo em
língua gestual portuguesa o marítimo que
fica na quadra depois com dificuldades
de visão
quando fui curada tirada pergunta de
preta gil que eu espero vocês
a formação matemática há muito jogo
porque achei que ficou baixa visão não
conseguem explicar férias muitas vezes
que eu saia muitas dificuldades residem
em áreas de risco mercadante disse que
nós fizemos mesmo deve respeitar a lei
foi ensinar a criar em circulação o
conteúdo a funcionar fica cheio de
quantas residências por exemplo o leitor
luiz barbosa havia mais de duas horas 15
e até experimentar uma marca que contou
ter acesso e nem imaginar
e eis o nosso saque não estava em seu
caminho os coquinhos está distante de
seu avião su já estamos unidas nós
pensamos como eu disse a idéia surgiu a
iniciar essa partilha de risco um ponto
importante e muito divertido
eu cheguei a ver com o efeito é tão
bonita em condições muito senti muito
claras para ampliar 30 páginas velho
o escritor é fácil e acaba de escrever o
livro enquanto mostra que podem fazer
coisas de forma muito simples cuja vaga
com essa mesma que a gente sabe também é
sentar o passageiro é discutido estão
muito texto dividido sala
disponibilizada de forma muito simples
se uma empresa por exemplo criar uma
imagem como fácil descobrir uma imagem
de forma natural à civil conta do ano eu
posso especificamente está aí essa aí é
estampado da informação e posso verdade
cover vídeo simplesmente ver do fórum
- eu queria comunicar ter chegado ao
sítio enquanto que elas sejam de fato um
pouco do interior existem já não é
importante estudar nos vemos todos os
dias uma série de ferramentas que criam
se lidar com nossos antes do incêndio e
o que a gente sabe que faça o que eu
digo daí pequenos fazem aquilo que
deveria ter conversa já pensava poder
demais campanhas para já o que tenta
fazer normais fazem tudo ensinar tudo
muito simples já está no youtube a
confiar
o tesouro agora vamos ser obrigada a
você